[Music]
I know this flexibility was one of the
things that attracted you to the Masters
program so let's start with why it was
important to you as well as your other
reasons for applying as you said the
flexibility was one of the main reasons
or important factors of wanting to come
and do this program I was looking for a
program that would be flexible in both
um potentially how the program was
delivered where it could be in person
could be remote and then the duration of
it where I could do it short if I want
to or I could I mean could take a few
years or I could kind of go in and out
if I'm working on other work projects
and then also content-wise wanted
something that was flexible that would
let me kind of pick and choose topics I
mean it have a kind of a concentration
of areas I was interested in but would
also allow me to focus on other kind of
tangential areas that that I thought
were interesting it was also really good
from a work point of view because I was
able to
um some quarters be able to take more
classes than others and then also be
able to tailor the classes I wanted
around what my work schedule was I was
working in management consulting for the
first little while so I actually was
able to use some of my classes for
projects that I was working on right I
would like choose a class that was
specifically similar to the project I
was working on and so yeah I mean my
papers were similar to my work outputs
yeah I know that something a lot of our
students really appreciate when they're
in the hcp program is that they can
immediately apply what they've been
learning so do you have any specific
examples of something that correlated
like that or kind of within a few months
oh yeah absolutely
um I mean a couple of examples apply so
one of them was working on yeah
Consulting project it was with an HR
department we were working on a
Performance Management Consulting
project and so there's HR classes that
you can or have to take so taking Bob
Suttons or behavior class uh really
valuable for that another one I was
working on a startup and we needed to do
like I was in charge of marketing so I
took the global entrepreneurial
marketing class and got I think there
were four four or five other people on
my team working on the project and
literally the entire project was all of
the deliverables I was doing for my work
and so yeah it ended up being really
nice
um
yeah because it also is nice because for
your homework you then have co-workers
reviewing your homework right and giving
feedback on it but also for your work
deliverables you have classmates and uh
professors or advisors giving a kind of
feedback on it so it's a yeah it was a
nice kind of virtual cycle and getting
feedback and and doing well on that I
mean the other thing is that's nice too
is I mean it's kind of like all the the
boundaries between those three groups
the co-term the external Masters and the
hcp are kind of porous yes right like
you can go back and forth right so I
mean I did my first three classes as a
like hcp or ndo student and then I moved
to a full-time Master student and then I
did that for the next I don't know 25 30
credits and then for the last little
while I've switched back to an hcp
student yeah and so it's really I mean
it's really nice to be able to go back
and forth and and like it really is
that's why in our admissions procedures
we kind of we we ask the question but
it's just something that would no not
huge because people can
switch backwards and forwards kind of as
needed during the program which is
really nice and so it's the same
admissions criteria it's all the same
degree yeah as well and then just the
ndo that you've been mentioning the
non-degree option yeah I mean one of the
trade-offs of like being like the ndo or
the full hcp is you can use that as a
supplement to whatever else you're doing
right so like if you're like working
these classes supplement your work a lot
of people who are coming back to a
master's program whether it's hcp or
whether it's the full-time Masters
they're they're coming back for I mean
there's a lot of reasons but often it's
you want to learn a lot you just like
like you like learning right that
intellectual curiosity yeah a lot of
curiosity there you didn't have the
career opportunities you wanted right
right out of undergraduate and so you're
like well what could what could amplify
that right and like so there's those are
probably two of the most common reasons
why I see people coming back and like
they're pretty generous actually that is
the other one is a career pivot yep you
see you see those three I mean overall
was an amazing experience
foreign